[Music]
we chefs like me I wanna not only know
but I want to be part of the action
[Music]
what is very important about indoor
farming is that this opportunity to
really understand the possibilities that
we have in the years to come to get here
in the world
[Music]
so at Bowery we build Smart Warehouse
scale indoor Farms you stack our crops
from the floor to the ceiling under
lights that mimic the spectrum of the
Sun so we can grow 365 days of the year
completely independent of weather and
seasonality
what we're really doing is not just
Reinventing farming we're actually
Reinventing the entire supply chain we
are locating our Farms close to the
cities that we are actually serving this
means that we can deliver our product a
day or so after harvest versus weeks or
months of time the traditional
agricultural system
Jose Andres has been an investor and an
advisor and a friend of Bowery for quite
some time
Welcome Center kitchen we are able to
respond in multiple events at once some
because the pandemic song because a
political uh situation and this is the
situation inside uh Ukraine right now
Hoops like me that within the world we
were finding many of the solutions to
solve many of the problems that we face
in the simple thing of producing food
when I saw what was going on and getting
the opportunity to be part of a
no-brainer power is which in the winter
is how do we maximize technology you see
the amazing theme of scientists of
researchers this is about producing but
it's a lot of research and development
that is happening
we grow completely pesticide free
produce so there's no herbicides no
fungicides no insecticides we're over a
hundred times more productive than a
square foot of traditional farmland and
we use only a tiny fraction of water
compared to traditional agriculture
what makes that all possible is a
combination of Robotics and automation
that we design and develop on our own as
well as the Bowery operating system
it allows us to control at a very micro
level all of the conditions and the
attributes around our crops and to
adjust variables in real time and that
kind of control allows you to drive
flavors and attributes of props that
we've never even experienced yet before
at Bowery we focused on leafy greens and
herbs as a start and we have the
technology we have the retail
Partnerships we have the know-how to
begin to move into new crops the
strawberry is this incredible
representation of what we can do at
Powerade
it's a fruit that's extraordinarily
seasonal one of the most pesticide
ridden fruits these aren't issues that
we face at Bowery and so we can focus on
variety and flavor and texture
using strawberry is quite awesome the
smell is unbelievable
it's a great strawberry if the
strawberries are as good as the ones I
taste today of course being my
restaurants totally
bringing the right technology the smart
technology to be able to produce faster
quicker better smarter less use of water
now doing strawberries that tells me
that the next crops will be even more
calorie dense crops
at Dowry we've been growing hundreds and
hundreds of variety of crops we're
thinking about agriculture for the
generations to come given the climate
crisis that we're dealing with today
more mechanisms to produce food in
sustainable way more chances we have to
solve many of the footages we face
the luxury to go to a farmer's market we
can bring that high quality local fresh
produce to consumers everywhere in all
types of retailers as well and we just
recently announced that we're building a
farm in Arlington Texas we're building a
farm in Atlanta Georgia as well and
ultimately moved from a national based
business to a global based business
I believe we need a very big ecosystem
to be the world doesn't mean that this
is uh gonna be fighting against the
smaller farmers in America around the
world I think it's wrong for everybody
so what you see here is very much uh the
future in more ways than one
[Music]